okay just easy I'll talk you just hey
reject nation how you doing it's Greg
Alva here and it's KC I'm gonna have her
say her name this time yeah say my name
we're gonna watch today from a channel
called what culture they're a fantastic
channel by the way uh-huh
ten trends that are destroying modern
movies boy I'm sure will agree with them
on this are you ready for this Casey I'm
so ready let's check it out there we go
in this day and age of warring studios
and films it's very clear that there's a
real consumer push to get bums in seats
studios are investing more money into
films than ever before and as a result
they need their projects to be a success
so we're trying everything and anything
to engage potential viewers from new
technology to filling its rosters with
the most famous stars the industry is
desperate to become a money machine
wherever it can is what we have
franchises sequels and movies based on
sources already in existence for this
move we're still getting a fair few
problems we're almost in a cliche of
cinema itself and while we are the ones
that can fix this by speaking with our
wallet it turns out that we are also a
huge part of the problem so let's have a
look at some of these issues together
and maybe eat a bit of humble pie along
the way with this in mind um Jules what
calm calm and these are 10 trends that
are destroying modern movies number 10
trailer spoilers are getting worse
actually spoilers they're all major plot
beats that were actually reveal in the
film's respective I'm just saying huge
problems for films as second or third
act twister regularly chucked into
trailers in the hopes of enticing a did
you just see that moment from viewer
many alternative trailers out there each
of which giving more and more of the
plot away in essence by the time you
actually see the movie in a checklist in
your head
yeah I saw that yeah and that yeah I
remember that joke from the teaser
blockbuster season is getting even
bigger the blockbuster season is in the
summit is to some degree arbitrary sure
there's always been a glut er
family-friendly fare released as soon as
the kids are out of school and the
fourth of July is always an attractive
slot because of America's still just
about dominates the industry but the
reason may is viewed as a big release
stage is mainly down to origins at the
blockbuster it is after all the month
when Star Wars first shook up the
industry the fallacy of this is only
being shown though with November also
being a viable release spot with Thor
Ragnarok and Hunger Games Catching Fire
cleaning up in recent times and the big
December release date has cemented
itself as a thing with Star Wars The
Hobbit in Avatar for example but while
these films released on these dates tend
to live alongside the more artsy fare of
award season summer remains a big
explosion dominated time and it's
getting longer marble have slowly been
pushing their big summer releases out
earlier and earlier rather than standing
out on its own it's merely invited the
competition to release earlier as well
it's good for the studios as it reduces
competition but if things stay the way
they are we might be faced with a film
gear that has a little space for
something that isn't an event
blockbuster or an Oscar hope that's a
good boy that's a really good movie and
half quality and there's no better way
to make money than to have a sequel it
used to be yeah Brahe story a beginning
middle and an end
maybe throwing a little tease of what
might come later like with Darth Vader
flying off into the distance or the
Joker card that mostly tired all of the
loose ends but that's happened now is
rare and many films adopt an open-ended
nature that keeps feel quite
unsatisfying amazing spider-man 2 left
all of the character relationships
deliriously up in the air and still
didn't deal with Uncle Ben's killer
transformers age of extinction left the
mystery of the craters which was a major
plot point totally unaddressed even dawn
at the planet the aides realized it
could make another film about the actual
world changing and instead had its final
act essentially be the conclusion of the
B story essentially movies are become an
extended trailers for their own sequels
and we keep lapping them up number 7
yeah we do
that was suddenly transplanted in Hong
Kong rift in Pacific country where
everything goes to China now looper
we've got a scene in Shanghai the same
city that BOM visited in stifle Iron Man
3 had a 15 minutes extra available only
in Chinese theater even Disney's doing
the Mulan movie similar decision America
so it's now abundantly clear to be
successful you need to crack China and
the easiest way to do that is set your
movies there the problem is is that the
more prolific this becomes the more
unoriginal it will be
it might seem refreshing now to see
action set in other countries but for
the same reason that we've grown
fatigued of America being the play
center for all the punch ups so too were
the likes of Shanghai and Hong Kong in
years to come from every single chair
against the franchise Factory yet for
all of the complaints about this very
real trend we still as a viewing public
only seem to engage with you guessed it
sequels and remakes seriously in the
first half of this decade only three
films have made it into the worldwide
box-office top ten that aren't based up
an existing franchise or are a big
animation from a certain house of mass
inception interstellar and gravity the
reason behind this is that watchers see
much happier seeking something familiar
a new idea is simply a risk that people
won't want to take number five musical
tie-ins are getting cynically obnoxious
to call in entire eyes on film studios
look to tynus many features in their
films music is a good example of this
with artists writing special songs on
film and their music videos containing
sequences the film to be dropped on
music channels and babbled on I love
that
containers on Scarface action scenes are
created solely to you thank you and as
all of the other sound dies down so you
can get that minute of hard
thumping bites I've realized you're
actually just watching my ass sure that
was not necessarily storytelling at its
finest when you watch some marichoube
and could knock up together in their
spare time what excuse me when I smash
on some showing down we have a fight of
the houses back please give us a sequel
there's something rather dirty about a
sequel whacking a giant number two on
the end it may have worked and being
cool when the Godfather did it because
it's groundbreaking but now it stinks of
a cheap cash in on the original extras
the solution used on and off ever since
Star Wars was to chuck a colon in there
starting off small with adding a phrase
to an existing title a la babe pig in
the city it was a bit in your face but
pretty harmless in recent years however
it's become unbearable because nowadays
it's an indication the studio is angling
hard for a franchise o parts of the
Caribbean Prince of Persia all boasts
first installments with an added
subtitle while transformers Thor
Resident Evil The Mummy the purge of the
Avengers noted the museum accident while
at the Hunger Games and Mission
Impossible Hook all added the colon for
their sequels amongst many others as you
can tell from the list or not all bad so
bad that Lee feels a sense that single
movies to mark into an episode of a TV
series rather than an event in itself
and once again adds to the deluge of
sequels already flooding the market
number three product placement has been
turned up to a level a corporation's
patients get their product featured in a
movie as far from movies getting help
with the budget and by having a few
Budweiser songs pop up and if you're
doing it well we shouldn't notice but
the same as it's true when you've got a
blockbuster that has multiple scenes
that pull you out like Magneto's raising
if the RFK Stadium was cool and all but
all we could focus on was those giant
pseudo period adverts with God and Pepsi
and I mean do we even need to mention
Adam Sandler's
in a la bond for the likes of Dunkin
Donuts Schilling set picks
this man is it's not a newly emerging
issue it's just can see that done right
product placement is subliminal
advertising that finds its way into the
film way things are going now though the
film is working its way around these
yeah number two
everything's reimagined when the memento
director Christopher Nolan chose to
deliver a brooding realistic take on the
dark night of Batman Begins was actually
doing something totally new for the
character back in the eighties obviously
we had Frank Miller and his
revolutionized Bruce Wayne in The Dark
Knight Returns and year one basically
they were Batman's life with a pitch
black tits since their Dark Knight Yugi
has come out we've seen all of these
slew of imitations that didn't quite
understand the message that was trying
to be put across no matter how original
the property we've seen the likes of
Alice in Wonderland
Godzilla Maleficent Snow White and the
Huntsman Hercules TMNT and even Batman's
brighter counterpart in Man of Steel all
going the way of gritty reimagining and
that's just plenty of other films have
taken elements of their characters and
tried to make it more real
seeing childhood heroes old and past
questioning their morality is fun at
first but it begins to where when it's
the only thing they do and number one
producers are overpowering oh yeah in
recent years when Edgar Wright left the
ant-man project he'd been working on for
eight years the intimate details
probably won't be revealed for a long
time but as write put it in 2017 I
wanted to make a Marvel movie but I
don't think they wanted to make an Edgar
whoo-hah in other words that producers
took over the bills protagonist Scott
Lang is much more of an antihero than a
straight-up good guy acquiring the
original ant-man suits during a burglary
big keV aka the head of Marvel didn't
like right pushing this aspect and cool
for loads of rewrites the director
wasn't impressed and tensions frayed but
this isn't the first time that Marvel of
clash with their directors and it's
really just another case in a long line
of studio interference the likes of the
marvel exact have as much of an impact
on the finished product as the director
themselves multiple marks on a project
are not inherently bad but when one of
those Minds is acting as an avatar of
the studio putting money ahead of
everything else the detrimental effect
this can have on the film's obvious I
was really pulled into that video
[Music]
well thanks for watching guys you can
subscribe to the real rejects let's call
it a day Casey I thought this was a
great list up sometimes I see lists from
what culture or other videos like Casey
does list videos for Screen Rant
and the richest and I usually completely
disagree with her any you laughter them
I watch all of them and all the negative
comments are my several YouTube accounts
take you down yeah cuz I feel like if
you have less of an ego you're more
likely to come back on this yeah sure
it's working it's working that's how she
got here the first point about trailer
spoilers are getting worse that's been a
problem forever actually I think it's
very common to see a trailer a go that
kind of gives away the whole movie we've
kind of necked like this is a brand new
thing but it's not it's actually not a
brand new thing if you go back to
trailers for like the 70s or 80s or
whatever you'll see that those trailers
give you everything so we [ __ ] about it
but it's always been that way kind of
feels like it has been HBO does a good
job of not doing that I mean that's TV
but like with Game of Thrones and
Westworld you're just like I don't know
what any of that meant it's kind of
funny that they point out that in or
seller an inception or two out of three
original films that have broken
worldwide box-office Nolan and JJ Abrams
they're the best like making you go
don't exactly know what this is but I
really want to see you know JJ is really
good that he likes mystery - JJ kind of
gets on my nerves because he's all about
a mystery box that never has an answer
but trailers yeah I do agree they tend
to give away too much but don't stop
making them don't stop doing that I
don't like it when the comedies all of
the joke worse that's just like come on
that's the worst one like the best jokes
are in the trailer van I hate that too
but then he is I feel like comedy can be
even harder than advertised if you don't
have like consistently funny jokes
throughout you got no choice but to use
the best jokes yeah
blockbuster season is getting even
bigger I think is another great point
every month is
yeah so it kind of makes luck busters
less exciting or less special you know
what I mean let's say it was like you
know Black Panther huge numbers know
infinity war it's like huger numbers
just keep topping it so if you think
it's going down or do you think it's
helping I don't know if it creates this
awesome momentum snowball effect or if
it's just gonna get overwhelming after a
while you know I feel like that's what I
keep trying to make their films even
crazier now and bigger and then make
them even more special when you go to
the theaters like IMAX converted the 3d
trend is kind of going down now people
don't seem to be gravitating towards
three anymore I feel like I was trying
to make them bigger too because most
people are streaming now do you remember
there's a time where movies used to come
out like a year you have to wait a year
before I came out on DVD or VHS right
now once that theater is like a month
later they're on DVD so you just wait
sir the animated movies - is that the
way like a whole year it's like pretty
immediate I do kind of feel that way
like we drop the word Indy season yeah
we're probably never gonna get that
that's what I think all Oscar movies are
pushed to like December we got no other
choice why can't we have a blockbuster
and an indie film in the same month
what's wrong with that I don't I'll call
Hollywood for you I'm sorry movies and
halfway through this story that's
annoying
I think the last time that really pissed
me off was Hunger Games Mockingjay the
last one the part 1 of Mockingjay right
that pissed me off right when I was like
you just like cut your movie halfway
through it's not even like a solid
chapter conclusion right it just
abruptly ends and that gets on my nerves
when they do that I could see something
like how Lord of the Rings even one of
those felt like a whole chapter was
likely but then now sometimes they do
that we're like oh god yeah I was just
thinking about Harry Potter because I
feel like Harry Potter does a good job
of keeping them individual movies but I
thought that would be yeah cool
when is the movie exactly sometimes it
works really well because I think the
Dark Knight did that perfectly yeah it's
like yeah technically the story is not
complete but if they never made a sequel
I think it'd be fine maybe you know
that's a really hard line to find I
think you got to finish the story and
then start a new one and cut it off T
something I missed those days where you
would end a story movies are becoming
just an expensive TV show you tuned in I
was thinking that's what the MCU is a
big television show watching all these
series that are like Game of Thrones
that I mean they're like an hour so each
episode and I'm like this is seven
movies movies that I've just watched TV
is becoming movie quality and your
movies are becoming TV in actual
conversation with Regan Casey tonight is
complain about sequels we will watch
anything else especially in LA I hear
that all the time every movies a remake
or sequel stop [ __ ] watching if it
bothers you so much is I'm already at
that point where I've just grown to
accept that it's just a genre to me now
right it's like a brand it's like yeah
why do you buy this paper towel over
that paper towel because sequence toilet
paper one before and my mom used to this
one and my neighbors use that name
identity yeah the familiarity that we're
all just throwing accustomed to I kind
of just feel like the original ideas are
not as pushed in front of our face
they're still there though yeah like the
movie still exists like get out was an
original idea yeah the only original
movie anyone could see into reference
yeah I like when your head goes like
halfway we'll get out I mean we just saw
each other for a movie called hereditary
which looks great quite a quiet place is
killing it the box office right now
that's an original piece of content just
has to be horror it just has to be four
words it's a bigger [ __ ] about or some
crazy Oscar season push these musical
tie-ins I do think that can be annoying
that's weird though I've never
we noticed Suicide Squad yeah exactly
that imagine dragons whatever saw no I
don't you know you got me in a pickle
here the best musical time I think in
recent years was the Wiz Kalifa song see
you again for Furious 7 oh yeah because
I was all in tribute to Paul Walker okay
and then they use it in the ending and
that makes sense right but when I hear
like that Suicide Squad song I'm like
sure this song in the actual movie maybe
at the credits I'll hear it like a lot
of kendrick lamar and black panther - I
was so looking forward to that whole
movie being all Kendrick Lamar like one
song yeah dad never excites me now
wonder if I hear that like when I heard
Kendrick Lamar was doing that I'm like
coolest it's gonna be a Kendrick Lamar
album it's not really gonna be in the
movie but everyone's getting excited
about that product placement has been
turned up to 11 I haven't noticed this
but these are gross I think especially
in the giant blockbusters it's way too
noticeable I just noticed it being
really gross in music videos lately oh
boy so you're using that specific phone
it's like very much like a glamour shot
of the product in the music videos I
haven't noticed this I definitely
noticed it in like the spider-man ones
for sure
transformers they are not shy about it
shameless I've noticed it mainly in
action movies with their cars oh it's
like Bond drives an Audi or like Tony
Stark always that same shop the zubur
becomes a car commercial for like 30
seconds well yeah when car companies
advertise in the movies I'm like who are
the 15 people they're selling this -
I'll see an Audi commercial in an Iron
Man movie but I'm not like I'm gonna get
an Audi once this movie is done you're
like who actually does that subtle
brainwashing a little brainwash you're
rich like Tony Stark
you should aspire to buy it for the few
billionaires who are watching this movie
it's gonna take I thought that like
everything they said here is absolutely
correct like every every single trend
and I can't really think of anything
else that's destroying modern-day movie
trends you can't do anything else what
it what is why say that comment if you
can't you get something at the top of
your head you can't think of anything
really really great they're starting to
be it too much of a rise of diversity
yeah I just think like we need to go
back to only white people and role -
we're getting delirious filming too long
subscribe to the reject nation click
notification bells the subscribe buttons
don't mean jack [ __ ] on YouTube anymore
Casey follow her on Instagram and
Twitter she is a burlesque dancer so all
that I'm trying to get the male
demographic of this channel Wow that's
fine let them hate on you okay it reads
as engagement Casey is a stripper in
North Hollywood make way more money I
would be to the wrong business which is
we're gonna strip club why are we here
let's go oh god I should [ __ ] myself
havin Sepulveda Boulevard you know be
sad as if you did that and nobody bit
like you didn't get any business I feel
like you think that's what would happen
a mic
oh I'm gonna bring